es ist eine einsame welt die hideo
kojima da zeichnet seine vision von der
zukunft besteht aus vereinzeltem bunkern
in die sich die letzten menschen
zurückgezogen haben verbunden nur noch
durch kuriere die durch wildes
unwegsames terrain laufen müssen
an ihnen liegt es die welt mit
lieferungen zu versorgen und die
menschen zu einen
die durchquert diese enorme wildnis
allein und fühlst dich so winzig fast
wie ein insekt im vergleich zu der welt
die dich umgibt das gefühl der
einsamkeit drängt sich die auf aber
trotzdem traust du dich weiter in die
welt hinaus und das verbindet uns mit
ihr und zeigt uns dass wir am leben sind
und ein produkt dieser welt zusammen ist
man stärker eine zugegebenermaßen simple
botschaft versteckt ist sie jedoch in
einer hochkomplexen und skurrilen welt
der spieler schlüpft in den digitalen
körper von schauspieler norman reedus
und in die rolle eines kuriers mit recht
mondänen aufgaben er muss erst einmal
lernen sich sicher durch das terrain zu
bewegen denn wer stürzt beschädigt seine
fracht verliert sie vielleicht sogar
auch wegelagerer lauern dem spieler auf
und eine dunkle bedrohung der
namensgebende gestrandete tod in form
von schattenwesen verfolgt den spieler
um ihn in die tiefe zu reißen es ist
eine einsame und eine gefährliche welt
mit teilweise grotesken zügen um die
schattenwesen orten zu können ist ein
fötus in einer künstlichen gebärmutter
teil der ausrüstung des kuriers weil die
mutter des ungeborenen kindes gehirn tod
am leben gehalten wird verbindet es die
welt der lebenden und der toten
maz mikkelsen in der rolle des vaters
taucht in erinnerungen des kindes auf
film regisseur guillermo del toro spielt
einen wissenschaftler der den spieler
bittet keine bindung zu dem kind zu
entwickeln
es sei ein werkzeug nicht mehr das spiel
setzt dadurch auf eine fast schon
übertrieben eine emotionale fall hören
kojima lässt offen ob es der geist von
america first und braig cit war der die
welt von bats trending in diese
erbitterte isolation und zur
menschenverachtung getrieben hat aber
sie spiegelt wohl auch seine eigenen
erfahrungen wider
nachdem er 2015 den japanischen
publisher konami verlassen musste oder
ein unabhängiges studio gründete als
sich vor vier jahren mein eigenes studio
gegründet hatte habe ich bei null
angefangen
es war quasi ein kompletter neustart ich
hatte kaum etwas aber ich hatte kontakte
zu leuten zu mitarbeitern und künstlern
und eben auch zu den schauspielern mit
denen habe ich mich kurz geschlossen und
die tauchen nun alle in dem spiele auf
kojima gehört seit jahrzehnten fraglos
zu den bekanntesten und beliebtesten
entwicklern zu seinen auftritten wie vor
kurzem auf der spielemesse igs in berlin
kommen hunderttausende fans und auch
viele filmschaffende interessieren sich
sehr für seine arbeit auf einer
podiumsdiskussion nannte der deutsche
regisseur fatih akin kojima den bric der
videospiele das licht was in der ukraine
entwickelt hat die kleidung die
entwickelt hat die schauspielführung
also es gibt so rektor wies und das aber
wirklich ein echtes games die stimmung
die er kreiert ist eine ist eine
pessimistische aber dennoch eine schöne
stimmung und es ist das ganze spiel
sieht so ein tunnel und du du du spürst
du die hoffnung ja sowieso ganz am ende
vom tunnel und und das führt dich halt
durch das spiel das das ist doch sehr
faszinierend für mich und ich kann davon
nur lernen weil ich entdecke diese ganze
gaming welt auch gerade die welten film
und games zu versöhnen
das ist schon lange kojimas anliegen
lange zeit waren filme und videospiele
wie öl und wasser sie mischten sich
nicht doch dann erlebte das kino einen
radikalen bruch durchgeht
digitalisierung nun ist der
entstehungsprozess und die benötigte
expertise für die zwei
unterhaltungsformen fast identisch bis
zum letzten schritt weil die eine form
interaktiv ist und die anderen nun mal
nicht in zukunft werden die zwei noch
näher aneinander rücken und es werden
dazwischen auch neue unterhaltungsformen
entstehen
auf diesem weg soll das trading ein
weiterer schritt sein
das spiel ist alles andere als leichte
kost die fracht zu verteilen zu
transportieren und zu verteidigen ist
teilweise recht kompliziert und lotet
die frostgrenze der spieler ganz bewusst
aus es hält sie aber auch mit
erzählerischen mitteln gekonnt bei der
stange
ein skurriles hightech märchen das von
wohldosierter monotonie lebt